hey when we get there how do you want to
handle the entrances maybe you introduce
me and I come in this is a table read
Charles it's not The Donna Reed Show
Donna re was not worth it okay now
please do not start this journey by
alienating all of your colleagues with
some desperate attempt at peacocking no
peacocking put him in the
[Music]
house oh my God Loretta where is Loretta
Loretta is in her dressing room she is
pretty upset but she said she'll try to
make the party are you sure a party is a
you know what no no no no spit it out
Charles Heap some more suffering unto my
already fold plate there might be a
little room next to the
Despair and she's going with
me Dam it and you can tell those workers
on stage right now that if anyone lays
another finger on my sets I'm going to
wrestle them
to and Oliver putam never Taps
out you've had a minor heart attack oh
my god dad he said minor Willie I
mean plus that's just a write a passage
in the theater you know Bob FY had like
five yeah you know the last one killed
him right a you did read his biography
uh there are a few things we need to
talk about first is your blood pressure
it's 60 over 100 and is that high
yes and is high good
no uh I'm going to prescribe you some
medications but you need to change your
diet too cut out dips doctor are you
trying to kill
me
go creatures of
well let's
start um give me uh one or two seconds
to to to to collect my
thoughts you're SC
P your dreams are D now Welcome to Hell
and you're your own Satan
yes like a good neighbor stay f is there
ow I'm just saying that maybe
alternative financing might reduce your
stress well guys we are so so close why
don't we start fresh tomorrow
morning
hi
hi before I tell you what I'm about to
tell you I need your assurance that you
will not be angry
no no one wants wants to do the musical
oh no one well the cast most of the
people who would do it they don't want
to do
it
ah they don't want to do the
musical that's
fine perhaps they'd rather I take this
food and stab myself in the eye with it
and just stab and stab so I'll be too
dead to be humiliated when Donna and
Cliff get here which is 5 minutes from
now I I think they're just scared they
don't understand the show and I don't
either to be fair but I come from
television and I was trained not to
question a
script I have a theory yeah Goldie the
Wardrobe lady why do you say that cuz
she's utterly replaceable it won't
affect our show one way or another if
Goldie the Wardrobe lady Goes to Jail
the key here is to find a murderer that
won't cost me the Tony great that was a
real
help
well my pants are still on so that's a
good sign I have never heard filth like
what just came out of your mouth th is a
Christian Charles take the day Tom find
a priest pray it
out it's so solid so fully formed you
know damn Broiler know oh what the hell
I'm just going to look at this that's
what I'm going wow why why cut it why
not so
good oh my god oh so
sorry is that mine oh no I'm so
mortified let me get you some ice or
something no no no I I don't I I
actually don't feel anything I sure
no oh God
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love that little snort you do you do
yeah I do you're like an adorable little
piglet Oliver I should warn you when I
commit to a show I commit fully oh I
love it you would be surprised how often
people are half in half out oh Oliver my
kids need me oh Oliver my girlfriend
left me I only have a little fishy left
and I'm afraid of being alone I mean
this is the theater what else even is
there I agree totally so I I think I
understand the Constable but I'm going
to need your help to become the
Constable it's part of my process when I
did war games I taught myself to write
code incredible from my rle in election
I started teaching high school and
dating some
students okay go home excuse me go
home I've had enough of your inan
questions Matthew broadrick nobody cares
what denomination the Constable is or
how he'd finger a mandolin the Constable
is just the Constable his parents didn't
name him Rocky or Lawrence or Bernardo
you know why because he doesn't have any
parents he's just six GRS of Ink on
paper a few electrons in my hard disk
that's it I can wake up tomorrow and I
could hit the delete key and poof he'd
be gone eradicated from this musical
exiled from our reality gone like a r in
the microwave oh oh okay well see you
tomorrow morning 6:00 a.m. Nova Scotia
time oh I'm not lurking uh Lester wanted
to inspect the peep holes because
evidently some of them had been
installed backwards so I said well I'll
do it and he said you know the good time
is 2: a.m. so I'm I'm lying I just
wanted to say I'm sorry oh apology
accepted friendship mended you're hired
hello
anyone Oliver we have a big problem your
cardio conditioning yes that is a big
problem but that is not this big problem
it's Jonathan he can't go on he's taken
a bunch of pills and he is completely
out of it the leading man cocktail Jesus
why are you a coat stand how Jonathan
has got to go on who's going to replace
our leading man on 5 minutes notice I
don't know but we'll need someone who
knows his every line someone who's
studied his every gesture his every
intonation someone who never sought the
spotlight but is willing to accept the
weight of the detective's
[Music]
Hat how are you saying what I think
you're
[Music]
saying
at the edge of the world in the dead of
the night a light housee looms over the
ocean and a body lies curled such a
Sinister sight guts and Gore on the
shore nov es
scotian with that blood curling cry or
the innocent sigh of a
child well it rattles your soul as the
dark takes control it's enough to drive
you wild when you're a creature of the
night all alone the black feel your
sanity crack creature of od's first
quadruple can sing dance direct or act
you're a lot of fun creature of the
[Music]
night